three two one boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation we have a very
exciting episode today talking about
moonshot entrepreneurship and we have
Lance Cassie and Matt Bell joining us
thank you for coming on to the show
yeah greatly appreciate it and so we are
building DX labs over the last six years
and DX labs is really exciting
innovation tank for moonshot
entrepreneurship yeah yeah and this is
really important so it's coming out like
a crucial time for society to really be
actual izing these incredibly powerful
ideas for building a bright future so
it's exciting stuff to have you guys on
the show to talk about this yeah yeah
thanks so much for having us yeah thank
you so so tell us about this okay we got
moonshot entrepreneurship is something
that you guys care about let's talk
about why you care about it and then
we'll talk about you know DX labs how
that's amplifying it yeah I think it's
just you know over the years works like
40 or 50 startups and just started to
see a pattern you know conflict short
term thinking and the impact of that you
know on the company on a mission and
just thought you know I think we can be
more intentional about you know planning
for the future and identifying what that
moonshot is really early on so that you
have a better chance of actually making
happen yeah it's like yeah you you think
about we mean startup methodologies and
kind of like iterative thinking which is
you know the gospel of Silicon Valley
and there's a you know obviously many
many benefits to this type of thinking
but I think one of the byproducts is
sometimes you can kind of be
short-sighted and I think you know we've
seen over the years it's like the
companies that take the time to really
hone their moonshot and oh sure it's
like it's
simple you know it's it's visual you
know it's easy to explain a lot of the
the great things that you know
entrepreneurs that you want must do very
well that they have an easier time ever
like onboarding talent you know getting
investors all that great stuff and then
making sure whatever they're doing in
the short term was like aligned with
that long term vision yeah you know I
think it's extremely you brought up a
good point like it's extremely dangerous
like keep on playing into this short
term mentality and there's certain
aspects that are kind of coming out the
cultural aspects that sort of reinforce
this short term like I got a you know
get my sort of immediate gratification
and these products that kind of play
into that and that's a that's a short
viewed sort of way of planning for the
future I think that you you create
unintended consequences when you do that
and I think the the key is to be
extremely intentional like you were
saying with the with the consequences
not just like the vision that you have
but what is that future going to look
like and given the set of sort of
circumstances we have now and that we
can project into the future can we make
as accurate as possible it's not some
perfect the view of what that world is
of the world what what kind of world we
want to create is yeah I like how you
both put it into context in this short
term but so very feels just the words
that come to mind of the attention
economy for that short term yeah yeah
and just that compared to this long term
moonshot what's your vision for the
future how are you gonna sell that what
does it tell is it tangible how are your
short-term goals to get there just that
mentality versus the attention economy
are just two completely different and
that's your consciousness like your
whatever you're focused on that's where
you're spending all your energy yes it's
like where do I put my energy and I
think that's that's something that we're
just maybe because of the economics
don't work out necessarily in the short
term because we're not thinking long
term
we're reading for like encouraging that
so there's a feedback effect there that
we can maybe help manage thinking more
long-term yeah I think it's also kind of
taking a more holistic definition of
success and I think when you're looking
five to ten years out you it kind of
creates the space to like to think
bigger and you know you know science
fiction is one of the tools that we use
a narrative to explain like what's that
social impact going to look like and is
that something that we want you know is
that something that's desirable and we
think like the more we can kind of use
these simulators we can think through
you know these sorts of things and
hopefully the attention economy and kind
of yeah you know selling her our
eyeballs you know for marketing you know
you can kind of like it's kind of crazy
how you can take a few constraints and
sort of you know project them to their
logical ends and you can make yeah you
know I don't want to say predictions but
you can definitely create visions where
you're more intentional about making it
happen yeah you know end up with you
know Facebook you getting audited by
Congress situations what you what you
just started painting there is what I
think we should start you know let's
start highlighting so you know the first
thing that you know that I really like
in what you guys are up to is your
multidisciplinary approach to things so
we have this good graphic that has like
six different boxes on it and
different projects or different fields
that you definitely like tapping into
yeah so before this one we're on let's
go to the one that has like the six
boxes says like you know drones and yeah
yeah exactly yes so we we were kind of
like technology what do you call it
agnostic right I don't care what the
technology is it is and it's it's more
about the problems you solve with it we
use them as a tool and we challenge
ourselves you know I think with every
project to learn more you know to kind
of bushwhack our way through to
developing new design principles to be
able to like leverage these technologies
yeah so we've worked on augmented
reality for Low's and doing like
interior layout kind of stuff area
learning mapping I kind of we've done
drones with precisionhawk for
agriculture construction all the you
know analytics and everything that's
associated with that and we take this
kind of like broad view you know think
about that whole kind of customer
journey what does it look like right now
and then we'll do what are we expect it
to look like five to ten years out how
hard is it actually right now for a
farmer yeah a aerial view perspective of
their land and what's going on oh yeah
yeah and you know you find this process
you finance amazing people you find out
you know farmers don't really care about
hardware they don't really care about
flying the drones I just want to get the
data data to figure out how to you know
optimize their yield and do you know
perfect of analytics and figure out
where to put the pesticide and
fertilizer and all that that's the
outcome and you know that future casting
process I don't know you know that we
can speak the results of that word but
yeah there's ways to do were you
automating the whole thing and you don't
so here you guys are covering these you
know very exponential technology futures
and like you're saying you're having a
really deep conversation with the people
that are experiencing the exponential
technology it's kind of approaching
their industry and you're asking them
how can we make how can we design a
future that works really well for you
exactly that's a really good point is
like you know often a lot of foresight
exercises don't work with the people who
would be impacted by them do you you
want to work with you know we were
talking with utopia cities and their
whole mission is how do we use slums I'm
gonna mess it up but it's like looking
to slums for inspiration and you know
challenging us to think about how can we
use sort of the ad hoc behavior of how
they problem solve with in slums to
inform how we design future cities and
so we did this the ultra casting session
with with people you know skyping in
from but the interesting thing was you
know actually having some people from
the favelas you know the slums in Rio de
Janeiro and hearing about their
challenges and how they make decisions
and there's kind of like going to pass
that you go you're in that scenario
where it's like really easy to you know
which is become a soccer football player
or you know join a drug cartel
there's just no other options that's it
but you know you're going through this
process whether it be a farmer or you
know somebody living in a favela you
want to make sure that they are bought
into that future happening you know it's
something that they can engage with and
that they're excited about and you're
co-creating the future so like you can
ask them directly so what are the top
four problems that you're facing in
the environment so in slums there was a
crime education security education like
you know what are those aspects I think
what's fun about this process too is
like we're taking a long sighted view so
we can kind of ask these these
provocations like what if the most
dangerous slum in the world was the
safest city in the world in ten years
mm-hmm
like what would that look like yeah how
would that look moonshot statements yeah
okay so okay so these are the industries
long-term thinking and asking really
thought-provoking questions getting the
people on board with that future having
conversations about that building that
community okay a very action-oriented
very moonshot oriented so Ron hit us
with the next slide I wanna show okay
now you guys you know this is a little
preface in kind of your methodology by
talking about Futurecast the future
casting for me sounds a lot like future
authoring feature off things this like
psychology technique kind of like this
career-driven technique yeah where you
just say you know in a year I want to
have achieved these goals and five I
want to have achieve this and ten
etcetera yeah so but idea future casting
and describe a moonshot and tell a story
about its impact on our society so you
have to tell us about that yeah I think
it's you know there's a lot of
methodologies and you know you can apply
to your life for your company or
whatever kind of project you're working
on but I think what they all have in
common is really creating this space to
suspend disbelief and really think
through you know be intentional about
what that vision is going to be and so
that future casting for us is like
looking five to ten years out sometimes
a little bit longer and unpacking what
that concept that main concepts impact
on our society or how we interact and
live as humans might be and narrative is
like a really good tool for doing that
you know as we've seen by you know
sci-fi inspiring so you know countless
entrepreneurs like most people are I
don't know most of the entrepreneurs
we've
worked with and inspired by some sort of
science fiction or some kind of love
story so the idea is like you know using
that as a tool and that we can wield
then they I think the the other
challenge with this you were talking
about before is like how do you connect
it to you know short term actions and
that that's kind of the the part of the
process or what I've seen in foresight
is lacking you know there's there's this
you know there hasn't really been a good
connection between like the big vision
and like it's very hard you know there's
a super art and it's it's kind of
daunting you know so so we've been
honing that process we call it retro
casting there's a lot of different names
for it
it's essentially like you build your
your vision your story about you know
your intended impact on society and then
identifying like what are the big
roadblocks to that happen happening so
you kind you know you got your
idealistic hat on to get your vision and
you know it kind of build that
simulation of success there and then you
know if you gotta take that hot hat off
put on your devil's advocate hat on and
and that's when you start like shooting
down the idea and figuring out like okay
where is all our failure points you know
how many launches of the shuttle do when
you do let's do this let's let's break
this one down so you're moonshot is the
moon your future authoring your future
casting yourself getting to the moon and
then you're sort of retro casting and a
realistic way of understanding what are
the impediments how are you going to
have this short-term goals of actually
getting there and so ok so this is a
really good methodology and ideology and
it also kind of gets people ready for
where a technology like you know we'll
get to a couple of these but genetic
engineering or neuro technology and
brain-computer phases it's like there's
millions of different paths that these
technologies go down so how do you
highlight these important ones and give
people to look at where we are today and
have these hard conversations
about what's it gonna take to get to
these more ideal futures rather than the
dark ones because you have to yeah there
is an actual path to get to the bright
ones and you got to follow the path to
get to the bright ones can't just say
I've hope it's it's interesting like
growing up you know and taking a lot of
dystopian futures like it's very easy to
say like what we don't want and it's
good to say like you want to know what
the what is the opposite of your goal
you want to know that so you can steer
clear of it and it's but it's much
harder to define what is ideal and where
you want to shoot for and I think that's
that's the fun part of this process is
we're actually getting a chance to do
that and it's just it's difficult that's
why people don't do it it's like you
know it's easy to see like oh it's a
latarian dictatorships like oh that's
obviously something we don't want but
what is the ideal Society beyond what we
currently have you know and it's not
something you do in your everyday yeah
we get a lot of opportunities to sort of
reframe especially in corporate you know
we've worked with a lot of corporate
skunkworks and things like that and
they're you know operating
quarter-to-quarter
some corporate skunkworks all right
working but it has to be it has to
become a habit this process of really
future casting your old life and society
and really thinking about that on a
frequent basis about what actions and
behaviors you wanna date it's a
discussion - so part of its being
multidisciplinary and when you look at
that you want people in the room who
have different viewpoints and like real
different people it's different ideas
they're holding and people who are gonna
be affected by it so the people who are
maybe powerless in the situation so say
there's you know autonomous trucks are
gonna you know wipe out 40 million jobs
let's do that let's jump to let's jump
to that graphic before we go so will
gets it back to the methodology let's go
to the forty the next one the next
graphic and we'll come back to the
methodology Ron so yeah come back to
this question go ahead yeah so like
that's one thing that's really
interesting to look at and it's really
valuable for like what will the 40
million workers soon to be displaced by
autonomous trucks do to maintain their
quality of life
exactly you know and
and one thing that's important to look
at is like these people who are this is
a worldwide sorry Worldwide's 40 million
u.s. is only like three it's the u.s.
it's that's the trucking industry so
includes truck employees
this is catalytics managers accountants
like logistics structure yeah wait wait
a sec wait a second that's not worldwide
it's great it's no way there's only I
thought there were only about three
million or so taxi and truck drivers but
then there's there's well there's 37
think this is looking at like the whole
shipping industry it's probably looking
at like even the flights and planes and
like that makes sense accountant really
that's like UPS trucks and flights and
see trade and all these because there's
a lot of pieces that go to that puzzle
sure sure reframe that to like logistics
right okay but it's the part of what I
find really exciting about this process
is you're taking a look at the people
are that are gonna be the most affected
by this exponential technology yes or
your proposed idea and and giving them a
voice through the story so it's giving
power to the powerless basically and
that's exactly to the people and and
that's its suit that's key and bringing
them into the discussion and that's I
think that's the part of the I think
that stories are a way to frame our
discussion and to get us to start
thinking about these things before they
happen I think humans for what three
hundred thousand years like world
history like we've been telling stories
to each other and part of it is to have
a dialectic and discuss ideas before we
take action or to discover like what's
the ideal future or ideal people like
who do we want to be how do we want to
emulate each other
and you know I think that there's a I
think it was Stephen King who said like
stories are basically a way like if you
write a story
it's basically telepathy between the
author and the reader and that's that
telepathy it doesn't care about the the
temporal line it's like it's across time
it's a timeless discussion that you're
having with the author and and you can
bring that into the discussion so so I
like how your you said you're giving
power to people by posing this question
so you know we love the power of quality
questions of really thought-provoking
questions and so it's all about framing
yeah and so you're framing this question
to the masses of people that are going
to need to be retraining in order to
have some sort of a life that has
meaning and purpose outside of what they
are doing today which is working in this
logistics industry so this is one of
many questions that you're asking we
have other questions in order
I can strain this up a little bit yeah
we have a publication called futures and
these are focused on areas that were
really passionate about and think will
impact society in a lot of different
ways and it's a tool for facilitating
conversations excuse me
so we host events and read these sci-fi
stories and we can talk about that in a
bit and yeah this one was looking at
what happens with displacement
autonomous vehicles at times trucks it
was like a few weeks before Tesla
announced their electric truck coming
out and everything oh my god amazing I
like that so you have the events that
and we're always six months ahead there
are some that are part of futures there
is the series and the newsletter and you
can sign up for that on DX labs
Yucko just join the newsletter okay yeah
listen the bio and so this this story
really explored if the workers are
displaced basically yeah how do they
maintain their quality of life and we
explored kind of two scenarios in this
courtroom case and there was like a
class-action lawsuit lawsuit by the
truckers who wanted to basically get
paid for
out of work for about a year to find and
and we explored like do you actually
have time to like retrain find another
job and we're kind of like telling the
story through the lens of the was the
CEO of the company
and so we created the stimulator and it
ended up like the private company
basically formed a program to be able to
take care of the displaced workers for a
certain period of time kind of like the
robot tax you know yeah and so we
published this it was on it was on the
first page yeah for a bit and we
actually had some workers comment on
this and be like it policy you know
rolled out like and you know XYZ I would
actually be okay with this because of
all this other stuff I was like I'm
realizing like this could be a social
prototype like people comment coming
back and if I'm ever getting into
automaton of vehicles are entering to
they have to replace the millions of
people that's it's not there necessarily
responsibility but if you do care about
this corporate social responsibility you
actually have a heart then which you
have to yeah so then the whole essence
of it is then if you are building the
autonomous vehicles the ones that are
gonna be replacing the millions of
people that are driving the cars right
now then what is boobers plan then to
help retrain example and and then that
is kind of like this threat of
conversation look we just came up with
this one solution yeah and there's
millions of these so many potential
futures so many potential futures yeah I
think that's something that what I'm
excited how-how'd it forms regulation
governance like policy because like we
worked on a drone proper project for
drone traffic management system and this
was like four or five years ago is where
they FA you know just didn't have any
policy around like can you fly and
mandate
and how do these whole systems in her
hand everything and sweedler with Future
cast after cast identified like you know
we have a way to create a network for
all the drones track location the FA
didn't have a way to plug in and monitor
that and how it interacts with the the
flight space so we built a prototype of
this like duct tape a drone back in the
day I didn't really have a great GPS or
anything like that yeah and we made
these collision avoidance systems around
trees and she's like I remember my
brother Darren I was working on the
product and he were flying full-speed
into these trees and we would smash them
like right in there I can't say that
that we didn't hurt new trees process so
let's let's go through your methodology
because I want to get through a couple
things before we get to some of the
pressing issues that I want to discuss
with you as well I'm Ron go back one to
the methodology quick so ok I like this
method about methodology I think it's
really important too as like a breakdown
of how to address the different futures
so ok who are we designing for and what
are their biggest problems ok that's
under discover that's what we're talking
about here with the farmer and actually
understanding the farmer their top four
problems like digging into the current
day problem space understanding current
solution pads are there any duct tape
solutions what's that customer journey
look like who's experiencing a problem
you know design thinking methodologies
are really good at unpacking what the
methodologies and then your framing in
the challenge in a way that's ambitious
and achievable so again it's very
moonshot driven you're not doing the
band-aid one here's another one that's
like what would this look like if all
your problems are solved maximally yeah
how do we achieve those goals along the
way
yeah the moonshot portion is probably
the hardest one to to get we're teaching
a class at CCA and
we love some cedar yeah yeah Fox it's
called designing at the edges of
tomorrow yeah oh great great I'm glad I
wanted something that like I would sign
up for in university yeah but yeah
there's some criteria for a great
moonshot statement that a Tom Kalil
who's that
we love Tom Kalil technology advisor to
Obama you're watching moonshot
initiative and he does a great TED talk
on it is but achievable some other
criteria it's like cattle at a catalyst
for creating social action because to
tackle a lot of these big problems you
need a lot of stakeholders to kind of
come together to totally and you need to
inspire and then here's the kind of like
the whole future in retro cast the side
of things that like towards I like how
you get teaching this as a class because
it totally makes sense as a breakdown as
a good really solid methodology yeah so
how do you tell the story how do you get
people excited about it how do you make
it how do you set up what are the
roadblocks how do you get there so this
is good I'm glad that we showed it I
think it's a good template for other
people to use they print it out you know
yeah print it out think and think about
it you know digitally fill it in on you
know any PDF filler software son sketch
and just go and execute build create we
always talk about that on the show you
can use crayons too you can use crayons
or markers crayons yeah yeah bring it
get back that colored pencils gotta
bring back one that's spirit from that
youth oh my gosh and this is something
that's like we we were testing it in all
these different environments
testing it in like urban planning city
design with startups corporate
accelerators now we're trying it you
know doing it in the university context
and we're kind of like honing this
process every time and we always find
like one little area where like
yeah we could frame this a little better
so if you guys print this out you got
feedback definitely like hit us up yeah
let us know your thoughts yeah Lance and
Matt at DX labs code right yeah cool
yeah so just find them on the interwebs
on that email exchange and send them
your thoughts okay let's go on to the
other let's let's go on to we were
talking we had the AI autonomous vehicle
car example we were talking you a little
bit about governance as well I want to
get to some of the other ones Ron let's
hit to the next one so okay the cross
just panned across get though get it
yeah we'll get us that full shot so part
of like the there we go there we go okay
well so so Ron Ron you want to fix this
up for us or once we as we talk about it
it's a little so we week to little whack
we joked about using crayons yeah one
thing that we've noticed is when we do
these workshops a lot of times you get a
multi-disciplinary across disciplinary
team you have engineers managers you
have people who are psychologists and
accountants or whatever they are yeah
and a lot of people are like oh I don't
want to draw I don't want to draw any I
don't wanna id8
you know and damn the thing is like it
really doesn't matter your skill level
if you draw a little icon or a little
graphic anything that helps you look at
the board and be able to associate that
with a concept it makes the process a
lot easier to handle so don't be afraid
of drawing stick figures it's okay no
one's gonna judge you need to be in a
judge listen vironment yes and that's a
cool stick figure I see what he's doing
yeah I agree with you there yeah you got
to be able to just just let it create it
yeah create let go yeah it's all about
getting
ideas tangible so that you can see them
and react to them and everyone has their
own you know ways of doing that some
people tell stories some people get it a
visual whatever it might be
yeah it's creative confidence it's part
of the reason for the stories and for
the the concepts that we do that are
paired with each story we want to
basically get it as concrete as possible
so that people have empathy and can see
themselves in that future and then
decide for themselves do I want that or
not yeah yes so you're really hitting
the emotional center of the heart and
getting people to think themselves with
the foresight so okay these are the
really good questions as well that you
know we like ask how could brain machine
interfaces be leveraged for political
gain so again you're you're really
pushing people to get that hey there is
some [ __ ] going on right now in your
world which you know with Cambrian
analytics and everything else has been
going on so what's going to happen with
the future of psycho metrics and deep
fakes and all the stuff and if you can
really press people to to get that like
a company like neural Inc even though
they are great in many ways could also
at any moment decide that they have
control of your mind
yeah spoiler alert they're gonna read
the story if there's control our minds
guess what it's already happening we're
already the thoughts of an AI right now
yeah I think the big question for this
exploration was really if you could you
know quote unquote improve anything
about your consciousness whether that be
through brain you know computer
interface or genetic
you know there's so many ways to alter
consciousness yeah would you would you
want to be able to you know take out
fear reactions or you know how our big
abdullah operates in certain scenarios
where it just doesn't make any sense
because we're not you know scared the
forest anymore there's a lot of things
that our brain kind of evolutionarily
just doesn't make sense right now and
that so this to argue with you I think
that's where it is like you you you
bring up those questions and then you're
like okay well if we took out fear then
what's our impetus to improve our world
I think fear is one of those things that
helps us create a perfect more perfect
society because we fear scarcity with
you lost me fear not having and so yeah
there's all these like like you said
like there's all these sort of
externalities or or adjacent things that
might be related to how how fear plays a
role in our consciousness so when we
mess with our consciousness I mean do we
need to fully understand how our brain
works first before this happens in your
thinking about the repercussions in
advance
really important yeah we might find
stuff that we don't understand and brain
definitely falls within that category
yeah this was a story about a politician
who was modifying things about his brain
yeah that would you know get him more
votes like basically you know heighten
his emotional intelligence be able to
read the nuances of public reaction and
know kind of like what to say it was
very intense
there's an there's a it's a good ending
there's a there's an aspect to it again
we we sort of talked about having the
technology be a character in the story
and the our main character that we
choose and the technology being foils to
each other and in this case the main
characters is this politician who's sort
of stuck in his old ways of how politics
used to work and he's faced with this
new era of politicians who are they're
all powered by a
brain machine interface it's already
linked into the into the the AI and
being super powered so he needs to
decide like what do I do to compete like
and does he go with it and the thing is
he's he's very much against it so you
want to we like to choose someone who's
gonna show we really test the premise of
this technology and so that's kind of
the situation that we these guys are
right there with black mirror yeah yeah
you're that's really good I like that
maybe making some shorter video content
is also a good idea along with write-ups
that you're making yeah it's this is
good stuff it can get people really like
you artificial infatuation my my biggest
thing with this sort of discussion and
we we had sort of we had a fireside chat
for this and we got experts on the panel
and my biggest question was like it do
you want if we could modify our brains
right if we had this brain machine
interface and we can modify our brains
at what age do we do that is it 12 year
olds deciding their ideal version of who
they want to be and now think about
yourself when you were 12 do you want 12
year-old version of you to decide how
you will be like how your brains gonna
form here I don't know five years ago
yeah exactly
it's it's very like when you don't
understand your your subconscious and
your then your sub your deep conscious
motivations and you're playing around
well being able to take a someone that
is birthed into the world and give them
access to all information ever and then
have them be able to figure out what
they care about within that information
and then what information it would it
doesn't work that way that's why we're
all in this together not
not one person can have all the
information in the world get over that
yeah we're all in this together
with breaking places in my charge in
different areas it might change a lot so
it will change though over time even
though even though that is what it's
like right now it will change over time
and I was about to say that the even
distribution of this as well so who is
getting access to all the information at
what time were they getting access to it
how much does that cost which is when is
it going to be available to those that
are middle class or low or poor all the
all these types of questions are quite
important just think about if there's
like three four hundred elon musk's out
there everyone has this like the
unfortunate truth is that it is
extremely difficult to figure out how to
funnel resources down the hierarchy and
and unless we figure out how to do that
we are approaching a generation of of
quite the largest disparity so let's
let's show the next let's show the next
guy Ron the next guy the next image the
next guy the next image nice guy look at
this girl how my genetic engineering in
artificial wombs affect our society you
just did an event on this it's awesome
and this is intense stuff I mean it's a
genetic engineering intelligence
metabolism strength height eradicating
disease
women artificial womb gestation
happening outside of the womb
yeah there's kind of two I mean there's
two concepts in here artificial wombs
that one's really interesting not a lot
of people think about it I didn't really
think about it other than the sheep that
was born and inside of the bag you know
she stuff a bag cheap yeah but when you
when you think about it for it was
really interesting because the the
author you know has two kids
and you know she'd been through the
magic of you know giving birth and
really connecting your baby and all kind
of stuff and then you know one
conversation just kind of like really
painful and dangerous and you look at
child mortality and you know that all
the mothers that unfortunately die and
it's one of the you know metrics of for
developing countries is your child
mortality right like people have to have
six or seven kids because you know two
or three of them might pass away so
that's why you have like more kids and
the idea behind artificial wombs is like
what have you had the ability to control
temperature stimulation you know audio
vibration all you know and those are all
the biometrics that the perfect sort of
biometric you know environment for it to
develop you know it's specifically
matched here
and everything and it kind of you know
there's definitely like concerns about
like well the mother be as attached to a
baby that doesn't like connect with her
this way there was a great discussion
about that and you know you've been
pulling the audience and asking like how
many people will just think about like
that's a good question about the mother
and nurture that's a really good
question yeah yeah rods expression is
disappointing - shits about me you talk
about you know it's already happening
you know we're all in for a big surprise
I just want to let engineering
let's take this animal planet and try to
make at least one of them like us the
the good that's a good question about
the mom in nursery in the womb what
other good questions came up like that
well just I mean you think about the
wooden enables the female you know the
the kind of like you know male/female
roles and childhood development and if a
mom is able to like work through that
whole time she hasn't taken maternity oh
the whole nine months she can just get
this Jam she can do what she wants
yeah that's a good that's a really good
point the mom can continue being
productive she doesn't have to sacrifice
her health but at the same time there's
this like holy divine process of growing
and inside of you but then there's all
of the incredible analysis that we can
do in the dynamic analysis of the
child's health and stuff and the
augmentations of it how that's going and
we had a one of the guest speakers we
had on the panel was she was concerned
with this idea of getting rid of
menstruation completely so you get rid
of that barrier you get artificial wombs
and now you've leveled the playing field
no you make you have an opportunity
where the wage gap starts decreasing you
know like that all these things could
effect a positive change in our society
damn food
genetically engineer away menstruation
so that you know she has another method
to do it with hormones I think that
would be pretty crazy to engineer away
menstruation and yeah yeah what so and
just moment to moment orgasm just like
trigger whatever you want just like an
orgasm
wait that's kind of what we do with the
social media anyway that's what we've
wired ourselves for that other things
that would kind of got brought up is the
idea what if he'll I must you know maybe
there were five hundred Neil I muscled
though empowered by brain machine
interfaces but what if he just a bite of
artificial wigs and replicated him
saying just filled them all with the
semen pretty kinky but yeah just all you
got to do is get your semen across you
know five hundred donor eggs and then
and then you're trying to find the eggs
that are as diverse and intelligent as
possible and then how do you fund the
you know on Genghis Khan how do you but
how do you fund you know what about a
woman a woman wouldn't want to do that
to she'd be like okay there's five
hundred of my eggs and I want five
hundred kids I'd be down with fathering
multiple children from multiple women
from multiple cultures I want a child
from on a black baby Muslim baby an
Asian baby a Jewish baby every kind of
baby possible teach all the brothers and
sisters the languages of each other but
that's what I want to do I want to be
able to afford that and I want everybody
to get along see that's what I love that
like that's that's you the one of the
issues is you we live in a culture where
people are sort of becoming more tribal
eyes are becoming more groups and so
like that helps yeah globalism that
helps with people understanding each
other better building empathy yeah
but part of it is like what there's a
extremely weird moral question of
ethical question that comes into play
like okay who has the power to create
these children and choosing the genetics
of they're totally and what kind are
they going to make an ideal man
an ideal woman an ideal person and what
does that ideal person look like it's
gonna depend on that so like we have
this culture now where I think it's
happening in social media where people
are getting plastic surgery to look more
like their Instagram filters right they
even donate that as a graduation gift in
South Korea I forgot it's a I forgot the
word for it but it's a it's a surgery so
that your eyes become more Americanized
yeah in the future you can just
genetically engineer ears and you know
look like a deer whatever you want so
okay so this has been really
thought-provoking and I'm really happy
that you're asking I'm serious a super
thought-provoking and really good that
you're bringing these questions to the
surface in both in live event settings
as well as out to different companies
and designing the futures and having
people view them over and really think
about them more and just the moonshot
vision and how to get there for
everybody I'm I'm really happy that we
now know each other there's gonna be
some good collapse that that yeah that's
been from this I some good event we have
some good events in my day awesome to
build so all right let's ask you a
couple questions on the way out that we
like to ask our guests do you guys think
we're alone in the cosmos you're sure
you're not can you be more specific do
you think we're alone there's
tardigrades flat you know floating out
in space there's like white flour grades
what is that they're a little more they
caught water bears are they on that
comment I think they can like someone
shot one of those and then those little
water there
yeah so you're talking suit okay so
you're talking about you're talking
about not being a loan because there's a
little like microbe feel connection
between them
okay what about well what about what
about do you think
well you're intelligent life has evolved
that you know that's do you whatever way
you want to imagine that but was it
Drake's equation sometimes we were
seeded you know you think we were seated
tell us about that theory that's the
plot of Prometheus
you know panspermia right the guy with
the hair and stuff your nose how about
panspermia though right where it's like
something collided with mars and mar the
lifetimes of Mars to earth well I just
think that's crazy so I can about like
an higher life-form plant into some
purpose right I figured something out
yeah or just an asteroid coming from
apart from away from Earth and planting
life on Earth in general so so into
course there's too many coincidence -
okay yeah okay so I think we can go down
that grab for a while okay alien rabbits
how about we ask you guys do you think
there that we're in a simulation I'm
almost like does it matter
it's we are yeah I think our
responsibility is to behave as if it's
not you know like we can take in so many
inputs
you know whether it is a simulation or
not there's we we have no way of really
figuring that out so it's our
responsibility to behave as if we're not
yeah but the likelihood you know based I
would mix Nick Bostrom and you know the
whole simulation theory is pretty
convincing that we are you know I think
that there's like there's almost a moral
or ethical reason why we shouldn't think
we're in a simulation because if you if
you assume we're in a simulation you
kind of assume the deterministic version
of the universe or whatever you do
doesn't really matter and then it's easy
to go from there to being just
nihilistic about everything like life
doesn't matter and then then you then
you go down there like a this weird path
where I just don't know about anyway so
so I just want to just a quick offer for
you guys just on the opposite side of
things regarding the simulation theory
one of the reasons why we asked is
because it expands people's minds the
new dimensions of thinking like in terms
of how bright our star is how close our
planet is to the star how long it took
for evolution to occur here just
calculating all these different
variables across different solar systems
and different and so you know for
example also sociologically how we
evolved here to have seven and a half
billion people where the countries are
how many people live in those countries
with how many nuclear weapons there are
because we are blowing [ __ ] up all these
variables when you crunch them and you
run another simulation how would have
earth evolved if you know the divine
feminine energy took over earth instead
of the patriarchy and we had a
matriarchy what would that look like you
know so running these simulations can be
fascinating and so we don't we don't we
don't know and we think about that we
ask it because we want people's minds
a new way so there's a show in the late
2000s sliders was that the time sliders
they like travel through a little portal
have the guy who is okay so basically
that was it it's like they went to
another portal and it was like nineteen
fifties but now it was like we're like
it was totally reverse you know it was
like okay well what if the women were in
power what if we were in a matriarchy
what if you're a society that there's
you know a different kind of structure
and testicles fascinating
yeah and it's it gives the great games
you gain epic empathy by looking at you
gain more understanding that's a good
futures overview what would what would
it look like if we switch to a
matriarchy that's a good one you should
have a like a divine feminine like panel
on that like it would solve a lot of
problems and a lot of problems but we
would we would we would have you know
some new the interesting thing is that
solve a lot of problems and create
problems as well we're all human yeah
yes so we're gonna human problems you
know like last question what do you guys
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world
Wow like it's that clear just like
wherever you want to take that
yeah
no Beauty I've been so inspired by like
that dear moon project and just like
think about how many artists musicians
and everything have been inspired by
werewolves it's love it
you know the Mayans like it goes back
years we got very lucky we got a moon
the moon has changed a lot of our
orbital dynamics and yeah that's a good
one
I'd say like the resiliency of like
humans of rational thought like because
we can be given all these indicators of
something like you know all these things
that could make us super superstitious
or you know scared or but like the fact
that we can work past those and start
finding the truth together I think
that's really important to me I think I
mean it's good oh yeah so I have like a
view of that I like that one yeah the
resiliency of humans over time and my
answer the most beautiful thing in the
world I have not thought about there's
it's very it's very difficult abating
I'm the question I'm the question asker
one of my favorite answers is the
collection of all consciousness
does a good answer there have been so
many good ones on the show oh yeah I
want to make you this is a good photo of
one of your events hopefully you'll be
doing some more events on like the
Divine Feminine or like that they'd be
so interesting if you guys chose you
know we're doing women an alliance event
shout out September 28th check out our
women in the Alliance event that'll be
very fun at work wise who's gonna be
there at 7:00 p.m. we will be featuring
Mackenzie slaughter who is the CEO of
beyond capital markets
we'll be featuring Nicole Bradford who
was the executive director of the
transformative technology lab and last
but not least we'll be featuring Mariana
saenko who is a principal at Khosla
Ventures it will be a fantastic and
super thought-provoking panel discussion
with very powerful women across a
variety of subjects and you may visit
our website at simulation series comm
and scroll down about halfway down the
page to find info and ticketing from the
event
perfect timing amazing you guys thank
you so much Lance man this has been such
a pleasure
I feel super inspired to continue the
thought-provoking questions talking
about those futures and getting people
excited about them
and doing that that whole idea of you
know future authoring you guys call it
future casting I love that okay thank
you so much for coming down the show DX
labs Co definitely go check them out
everyone go check them out also if you
guys had a good time comment below with
your thoughts we'd love to hear from you
join the community join the
conversations also you already know it
don't just consume but go create go and
make things into the world go and build
going right go and make video go and
start businesses go and make make make
create create create thank you Ron our
producer director much love everyone
peace
[Music]